If our objective is to keep the
mean squared estimation
error small, then the best
possible estimator is the
conditional expectation.
But sometimes the conditional
expectation is hard to calculate.
Maybe we're missing the
details of the various
probability distributions.
Or maybe we have the
distributions that we need but
the formulas are complicated.
After all, the conditional
expectation can be a
complicated non-linear function
of the observations.
For this reason, we may want to
consider an estimator that
has a simpler structure, an
estimator that is a linear
function of the data.
And then, within this class of
estimators, find the one that
results in the smallest possible
mean squared error.
In this lecture we will
formulate this linear least
squares estimation problem
and then solve it.
We will see that the solution
is given by a simple formula
that involves only the means,
variances, and covariances of
the random variables involved.
Because of the simplicity of the
method, linear estimators
are used quite often, especially
in systems where
estimates need to be computed
quickly in real time as
observations are obtained.
We will look into some of the
mathematical properties of the
linear least mean squares
estimator and the associated
mean squared error, revisit an
example from the previous
lecture, and finally close with
some comments on the ways
that this estimator
can be used.